so I'm Judy Stern I'm from UC Berkeley
and educational technology services been
talked a little bit about our
organization yesterday I am going to do
a couple of things here I'm going to
kind of tell a short story about what
we've been doing in terms of teaching
and learning using video at Berkeley
specifically from the perspective of our
organization and kind of the
organizations that fed into it and then
I'm going to kind of list out some of
the tensions we've been experiencing I
hope that we would have time to discuss
them but I think probably that's going
to have to happen offline so the story
has a couple of plot lines or threads
the first thread is the instructional
technology thread throughout the 90s and
kind of into this decade we had an
instructional technology program
primarily what we were doing
particularly in the case of video was
providing training and consulting so we
didn't have big production services we
didn't really even have small production
services the context at the time you
probably all remember it was a time when
they were easy to use be the authoring
tools HyperCard had been introduced in
the late 80s quick time in the early 90s
our goal roughly speaking was to help
instructors use technologies in ways
that encourage active learning the
outcomes that came that that came out of
this were a bunch of multimedia projects
for the most part cd-rom based in the
early 90s web based as we got to the
later 90s and of course you know one
thing that we were able to do was
provide greater access to video for the
students in ways that they couldn't have
access before we were able to introduce
some degree of interaction to make it a
little bit more interactive and there
was some small examples of student
created media which
you know where I think a lot of the
power lies but those were minimal I
think the challenges we were facing at
the time and actually still face are the
technology costs and by that I mean not
only I mean in the early 90s a
digitizing board was you know a thousand
dollars or more but also the time in
terms of how much time it was going to
take a instructor to invest in this
stuff to learn it to remember it you
know when they didn't come back to it
for a few months as well as I already
mentioned we didn't have the capability
the resources to provide services to
really help them create the media so we
were spending in a sense more more of
our effort on technology than we were on
pedagogy and the other big challenge was
a lack of scalability so a lot of these
projects were considered boutique
projects here's just um and I'm going to
skip over this this was a profile of one
of the instructors and it's just an
exemplar of kind of the kind of work we
were doing you know the big issues were
the cultural immersion that she felt
that she could get from the video she
did most of the work she took classes we
provided guidance along the way and that
was was common a lot of projects this is
an example from an educational research
project this was probably mid-90s
nothing beautiful but you know URL
flipping going on interactive video we
could click and change where you were
captions so we were trying to introduce
ways to make the experience more active
for students the second thread that
comes in is the
the second half of the 90s there was an
engineering research project been
mentioned it yesterday coming out of the
purple a multimedia research center that
was Bibbs the berkeley internet
broadcasting system context here was
real video coming out having different
web video options in particular
streaming the goal of that project
originally was to allow students to
review material from the lecture anytime
anywhere there were some studies done
and they did find primarily by looking
at usage statistics that students were
primarily using it as a study tool more
than half the students reported better
understanding and they liked the
self-paced learning excuse me I'm the
challenges there were some issues on the
part of instructors some were concerned
about attendance students not going to
their classes because the video was
available I'm in reality that wasn't
such a big deal the biggest places work
it was a concern was that eight o'clock
classes not surprising and then there
were some who didn't want to be webcast
as they were concerned about
intellectual property on the part of
students on the students not
surprisingly one of the ability to get
to specific content thing comes up again
and again this is just the interface
from Bibbs at the time beginning of this
decade those threads started to come
together so bibs became webcast berkeley
as it moved to our media services
organization our media services
organization work with merged with our
instructional technology organization
and became ETS so that's the
organization that my colleagues are part
of now so here we finally have you know
these kind of two different threads were
now you know different still different
groups different staff but we're all at
least under the same umbrella we came
even closer together between 2003 and
2005 when we adopted Sakai as an open
source collaboration and learning
environment and at the same time we add
significant development resources
because we were going to start building
tools for Sakai and in addition we
brought in an interaction designer who
kind of introduced the user centered
design process to our organization and
so now we're at a point where we were
saying ok so can we build a Sakai tool
that will enable video to be used to
improve teaching and learning I'm a few
words about user centered design and
it's you know hard thing to talk about
in a few years few words wait a few
years so basically the focus is on the
user's fully understanding the users and
what their goals are and what they need
to do before you even get to design and
I'll say a few words about some of those
specific processes that we followed but
a big part of understanding the user is
understanding their pain points so we
did some initial research Oh be helped
me at the time with this way when
talking instructors we did surveys and
so this is a very high level what you
know what were the pain points well for
the instructors who were not the ones
involved in webcast program their pain
points were still the technical you know
it's just too much work it's Britain
'some to get that video up the webcast
instructors still had some concerns
regarding attendance and that was really
the only thing that we saw repeated in
terms of their problems for students
they one of the things that was repeated
was they didn't have control over what
they saw the camera was on the student I
mean excuse me on the instructor when
they really want it on the board or vice
versa they couldn't see the powerpoints
clearly things like that and then still
again we find this repeated they had
difficulty finding specific content and
when we looked at what these pain points
were we said you know we can't in terms
of building a tool we can't address the
instructor pain points terribly well and
in terms of the student pain points
there were things that we could do in
the organization has moved to doing a
better job making sure the students
could see what they wanted to see but we
were going to focus on this aspect of
difficulty finding specific content
so from there we created our problem
statement which was a very valuable
thing to do especially in terms of
getting stakeholder buy-in sponsor
buy-in and making sure everybody was on
the same page and basically what we said
was that you know nothing mind-boggling
but you know we have this problem where
we have students who want to who want to
take an intentional approach to working
with this video to studying with it they
have good techniques you know we watch
students you know work with text they
know how to highlight things they know
how to bookmark things they can get back
to them but video is so opaque it's hard
to get into the specific parts that you
want our solution and it's probably
reminiscent of the projects we've seen
already or to provide tools that enable
students to mark points and timing video
and fine points for purposes of review
reflection study and completing
assignments and we didn't at this point
say specifically what we were looking
for we had you know looked at a range of
tools and had a sense that there wasn't
anything specific we needed so now we're
at a point where we're saying well this
problem of opaqueness is particularly
acute for webcast students you know
students using video all over the board
are having problems with this opaqueness
but the students using our lecture
webcasts we're having a problem is
really long form and they're you know
looking at them several times a week and
there's a lot of media there and at the
same time we're talking about growing
our webcast program so so now we're at
this point where we say okay what we're
doing is we're building tools for Sakai
that will help students more actively
used webcast Berkeley as a study tool so
just a little bit about the user
centered design process we went through
you know once we had reached that point
we continue doing user research really
observing students as they were working
with the webcast video we try to model
what we learn via personas opportunity
grams and moved on to requirements
definition and got to the point where we
had a conceptual framework design which
is really kind of a high-level sketchy
design but it has all the components
that we needed just just show you one of
the artifacts and this is our primary
persona Lisa the idea with creating
personas is to to develop an archetype
somebody who can represent all the
research that we've gathered not a
stereotype that's a really important
distinction and somebody who if we meet
her needs we're going to be meeting the
needs of others so it's not going to
spend too much time with her this is a
high level view of her anyways I can
show any bit more later if they want so
we had to stop at that point we didn't
have the resources to continue to build
the tool that was about Emilio and so
now I'm going to kind of talk about some
of the tensions and the first one is you
know we have a strong desire in our
department to improve teaching and
learning with new tools but we also
really have to deal with maintaining our
existing mission critical services and
so that's why we don't have resources
put on this project on the teaching and
learning aspect of this project just yet
we're dealing with a lot of the
infrastructure issues and just go
through these pretty quickly and people
want to comment on them afterwards they
can what we're not doing with this kind
of support for web cast is addressing or
promoting any specific educational
approaches we're building a more
generalizable architecture one of the
things that was attention for me at the
beginning and I'm kind of coming to
terms was it with with it more with this
whole concept of user-centered design
you're really looking to figure out how
you can reduce work for the user make
them work less hard to get to their go
and if you're interested in active
learning in a way what you want students
to do is work harder you want them to
you know put the effort into reflecting
interacting with the material etc and
another way to say that is you know
sometimes the student goals are not the
same as the instructor goals so and i
put instructor in quotes because of
their kind of all our goals we all want
the students to work harder some of the
things that's come up for me a lot of
this conference is how much information
students can have and yet how little
time they have to really access that
material and we know students these days
are capable of an amazing amount of
multitasking but I still have concerns
you know based on the research that we
did that lisa is not going to spend a
whole lot of time working with webcast
because she wants to get off a webcast
and go over to Facebook or Flickr or you
know what other whatever other things
that she wants to do with her personal
time issues of shared sense making
versus personal sense making this top
one back to that whole issue of
attendance well if you have if you're
concerned with attendance issues maybe
you should be making it class more
interactive but once classes become far
more interactive then you have video
that's far less useful in terms of
watching it as watching it as a lecture
and related to that is meeting the needs
of our students so again you know if we
want our classes to be more interactive
is it really going to meet the needs of
our worldwide audience
terms of being able to see what's going
on in a classroom where there's lots of
different things happening and i think i
will just end with this is a little bit
long this is from an article written by
Charles currents from Stanford he wrote
it in 2002 when he was the educational
technology manager for the open
knowledge initiative at Stanford but it
says a lot about you know where we can
be moving and I hope we move in this
direction at the same time that we
continue to really know what our users
want and need